I am really glad to be here today pi
data is one of my favorite conferences
because numeric computing and numeric
computing and data oriented computing is
one of the real the most important parts
of the entire Python ecosystem and it
really comes close to my heart because
one of the things that Travis in
mentioned is that my hobby in terms of
programming is actually around
computational linguistics a couple years
ago I I mapped the entire united states
patent database in an effort to find
better prior art and that sort of
brought me into the world scientific
computing and since then I've really
been working on it now that's strictly
sort of a medium data problem you know
my my core data set is only a couple
hundred gig but it still was enough and
it keeps me occupied to this day now
today I'm here to tell you a story this
is a story of the week overthrowing the
strong this is a story of the of all the
common of the common reaching out and
seizing the means of production to
overthrow those who have previously
controlled and previously controlled
those means of production and to become
rich by doing so and so I talked to I
said this to somebody and they said
you're going to come to Microsoft and
you're going to give a talk about
Marxist philosophy and I said yes except
this isn't really about political and
social philosophy this is about data and
when I talk about the means of
production I am talking about
computation and when I'm talking about
the raw materials i'm not talking about
labor i'm talking about the data and the
way in which it is where it is located
and what you can do with it but like any
good Marxist talk you have to start with
history this is enoch it's generally
thought of as the first stored program
computer although there are plenty of
people who would challenge that in
various ways and say no this one's early
or whatever this is as good as starting
places any now sometimes
there was this idea of comparing
different types of computers by looking
at the time it would take to accomplish
a particular instruction or series of
instructions and how many of those you
could do per second this was the
instructions per second you know now we
know it is MIPS if you looked at at
Linux kernel booting back in the late
90s they would list so until bogo mips
and they renamed it from mips to bogo
mips because this is a completely bogus
measurement it doesn't actually really
tell you what you think that's telling
you but it is an interesting enough
measurement that we can use it to trace
the perspective of history and computing
over time now heaney ack was blazingly
fast it was so fast that it could do a
total it could do about 35 instructions
per second that is 0.000000 02 MIPS but
even at the time that was groundbreaking
because the computer replaced the mark
one was an analog computer that could do
one of these equivalent instructions
every six seconds so this was
approximately a thousand times faster
and that was again an order to a
magnitude faster than the human
computers which the mark one replaced or
supplemented and so to give you an idea
of the relative speeds of how much this
first computer changed what it would
they the very first program it ran took
20 minutes the output of this program
was then was then checked by mckee by
people with mechanical calculators it
took 40 hours now this is what what
about data well II niak if you wanted to
input data and dini a kit can only store
about 20 numbers at a time and so what
you would do is you would go through and
you would manually create your your data
flow by plugging in patch cables every
player everywhere and turn the proper
input knobs and then he would run run
things and you had to bring the data to
any act because a niak was huge I looked
up a couple stats on it it contains
17,000 468 vacuum tubes 70,000 resistors
10,000 capacitors 1,500 relays 6,000
manual switches and 5 million different
solder joint solder joints it covered
1800 square feet of floor space weighed
thirty tons consumed 160 kilowatts of
electrical power and you could literally
park a bus in the middle of the computer
so the important thing though here is
that you had to bring the data to any
act because there was only one and it
was so big was never ever ever going to
move and this idea of bringing the data
to the computer continued even as
computers started to mature through the
50s through the 60s and 70s this is a
picture of a one of those glass-walled
glass-walled central computing
facilities that was very very common
especially on Wall Street in the late
70s what would happen is if you were in
a university or if you are in wall
street or the few other places like the
oil industry that used computing you
would submit your program to the IT
folks who would run it for you that data
processing folks and sometimes a week or
two later they would give you back your
result and if you had a bug in the
program or didn't do what you wanted you
would go through and get your set of
punch cards and you would rework it and
you would submit it again again look at
where the data was the data was brought
to the computer because these things
were big and they were they had a staff
that was dedicated to this idea of
feeding them data because only by
feeding this centralized computer the
data were you able to get back the
information that you needed in order to
make decisions but a couple interesting
things started happen as computers
became more powerful
and a lot of they started to happen
right around nineteen eighty so of
course the most let's see wow that's the
glass-walled room am i behind okay
that's henoch that's the glass-walled
thing evidently I skipped a slide but
what this was going to be was going to
be a picture of the one of the 1980s pcs
by IBM and two interesting things happen
with the IBM PC the first is that this
was the first PC where the data was
designed to be primarily processed
locally there was this idea that people
would really want to have their
electronic recipe book and store it in
store it on their computer in the
kitchen now this is crazy because I
don't know how many of you have ever had
a computer in your kitchen and had it
been had it open for you know for
checking while you're trying to cook
this is not this frequently does not end
happily but this would this was this
idea n of the spreadsheets that really
drove a lot of the business use this was
again process the data locally and then
put out the information the other thing
is that computer started become
networked and so you be so you started
to exchange things much more easily in
information and results much more easily
between them ethernet was developed in
the late 70s and then and modems became
standard equipment probably by about at
least a standard option probably by
about 1983-84 that's when we had our
first computer and it came with a modem
as a standard option no people have here
have been able to observe the changes
since that time we've observed the
change where almost every household in
the developed world has a computer and
for most of us in this room I would dare
say we probably have more than one I'd
say that for many of us we have more
computers than we have cars or TVs and
this is sort of on the strict
definition of computers but in today's
world we don't just have access to
computers as we thought of it back then
we also have access to phones and two
tablets and to all sorts of things and
we in looking forward to the future
expect that more and more things are
going to become imbued with computer
like intelligence because we're putting
computers in them so I thought it would
be interesting that starts with graph
what does the power of computing look
like over time and so this is a totally
totally these are billions of Giga
billions of Giga mips which is and this
was very very rough data but the trend
is very clear pc sales aren't linear and
that currently in decline but they're
still on average more powerful than ever
but what happens is that because of
what's commonly known as Moore's Law
this ability to have more and more
transistors we are seeing an increase in
the power of the computing
infrastructure as a whole and what's
more individual compute power associated
with an individual CPU is becoming more
and more powerful this is the graph of
again MIPS a bogus measurement but MIPS
over MIPS on a single core over time and
this is this is the well-known this is
well-known exponential graph now one of
the things that is said frequently is
that one of the things that's impossible
for human minds to fully comprehend is
the power of an exponential function
that is because we think of things
growing linearly or at least
geometrically but this idea that things
will double tomorrow or over a very
short time simply blows our mind so if
you look at the total manufactured if
you took look at the total manufactured
cores and you look at the power per core
then you can start looking at them and
each year CPUs get faster
us get faster and more and more gadgets
are sold and so you can actually get an
idea of what does the total computing
power look like that has that is
currently addressable at any time
because you can actually create a
measurement of how much stuff has been
manufactured and how powerful what are
those things and you can look at it and
the graph those pc sales looks like
something else ah so like i said sorry i
lost my train of thought so i mentioned
that the thing that's in the thing
that's interesting is that we don't
really understand this idea of an
exponential function the reason why that
it matters is because you can look at
this the set of all computing power that
has ever been created ever and what and
the amount of it that was created last
year and as those who those of you are
watching closely saw the amount of in
the amount of computing power that was
created last year was approximately
forty percent of all the computing power
that has ever been in the world from the
dawn of time and what's more well what's
more this is only going to increase and
so what how does this break out well
turns out that the vast majority these
are still pc sales pc power because pcs
are far far more powerful than the
phones and the tablets and the little
IOT devices that are out there but
things are moving up relatively quickly
so how can we make this computer
architectures and software are vastly
different and there's the there's the
issue of not only of how you the compute
core itself but the memory pathway which
is an increasingly important part of the
total bandwidth because ever since
actually the 60s compute cores have been
significantly faster than any any of the
memory that they access even the on even
some of the very fastest on-chip
flip-flops it still causes a minor stall
of the on the order of a cycle or two in
order to get information that's even
right there on the chip but if you look
at synthetic measurements associated
with say 7-zip or AES or some of some of
these other things that you can do that
are designed to work identically across
different types of computers and across
different different places and have an
identical output you can start to
extrapolate the relationship over time
and you can actually do these
compliments a comparison of total
compute power total compute power and
look at it look at it first on look at
it associated with both pcs and the
various mobile and IOT devices now IOT
i'm going to i keep on mentioning it for
the most part if unless you include the
little like the the microcontrollers
which are out there of which there are a
metric ton i'm going to be largely
excluding IOT in a lot of the in a lot
of these calculations because there just
aren't a lot of those out there right
now we expect that those are going to be
big those are going to be important but
right now the really growing trend is
associated with associated with mobile
now if you look at this how much of it
is not just it's not just how much
computing that a particular device has
but we also want to look at how much
total computing is not just out there
how much can i address at this
particular time because certain things
have been in there you can't send a
computer program to any a Kenny more and
there are whole lots of their whole
bunch of things that are just not
networked in not available so how much
can we address and it is and what's
interesting is that the new compute
power that is coming online is becoming
more and more significant and so if you
look at the cumulative power you
see the we are already in the position
where what's coming online each and
every year is far more significant than
what is going on and in fact we estimate
that very very quickly more than half of
all the computing power ever created is
going to come online each year which
gives you an interesting thought about
obsolescence you could throw away
everything that has ever happened in the
past start new from today and you would
still be able to have a computing base
roughly half as powerful as all the
computing in existence if you if you
threw away everything that hat didn't
wasn't exactly one year old this changes
the way in which we start to think about
computers and their disposability and
the way we address them What's in
looking at this a lot of this growth is
being driven by by like I said mobile
and tablets now on the logarithmic spell
PC compute scale compute power divorce
that of phones and tablets despite
tablets being more powerful on average
than phones phones there are just so
many more of them when we talk about
clouds we talk about a million nodes
being an extremely large cloud however
we talk about billions and billions of
phones being out there and these phones
are following the same curve so we
expect that so what does this look like
in terms of projection tablets will
probably surpass phones relatively
quickly because they are more because
they are more powerful and they will
probably be the first one to cross over
the top of pcs in terms of total compute
power available across the world that
you could that you could access at any
given time but probably by about 20-25
the most most computing power out there
in the entire world is going to be
sitting in people's pockets it's not
going to be on their desk it's not going
to be in their cloud it's not going to
be any of the other places where we
traditionally think of computers it is
going to be on the on people's persons
it's going to be scattered all over the
place but now this data is obviously
highly questionable in the specific but
the trends are strong and they are clear
and for all so just for people's
interest this is what the what growth
curves tend to look like that's a sort
of a best fit line for for these
different things now what does this have
to do with data and the answer is
everything remember we have always had
to bring data to the computers and there
were studies that were done there were
studies done as recently as 2011 that
said which is better a bunch of wimpy
cores or a strong core and the answer in
two thousand eleven and two thousand
twelve was that a single strong core
could do more work than equivalent
number of wimpy cores this was
especially when ARM arm processors
started to become very prevalent and
people thought what if I packed a whole
bunch of ARM processors into a single
box could I get better price performance
than a really powerful xeon processor or
or whatever whatever Intel most recent
one is and the answer was no and so it
was easier to centralize the computing
even within a box but the chain but what
is happening is that that trend has
actually started to change not because
the wimpy cores are getting more
powerful because they are but because
we're seeing certain scaling limits a
source associated with bigger processors
and a lot of those have to do with very
fundamental physical content fundamental
physical constants so I can't even speak
the speed of light can go about foot 13
13 inches in the time it takes
for a single clock cycle that is the
farthest that you can get your
electrical signal within that time
because of that you can the bigger and
bigger that you make your your central
processor the more interconnects you
need you have thousands of you know you
have miles and miles of actually lines
inside that processor and so it takes
time to start moving signals across the
processor this was most clearly shown
back in the pentium 4 days when they
included a number of stages in the
processing pipeline just to allow the
signals to propagate from one side of
the computer to another when we think
about this idea that the wimpy cores are
becoming the more powerful ones in
aggregate because they have more
Headroom and because they're because
they're in more places then we start to
think about the way in which we address
data and the way in which we address
computing and we need to start
rethinking those things so this gives me
the question leads to the question where
is data now people shout it out where is
data that was not exactly what i was
thinking steve then but if you if i were
to ask you where is the data where would
you say it is where is it located
everywhere the data is everywhere a lot
of the things that we talk that we think
about are actually us are actually
information product our information
products that are associated with
bringing data back into a centralized
location in order to do the computing on
it let's think for example about the
example from of this morning this idea
of the connected cows I loved this
example because they strapped
essentially a little computer to every
single one of these cows and they
brought it all back into a data center
into the cloud in order to produce
really interesting results and really
interesting visualizations but if you
think about it moving the data is
actually a very unnatural act we did a
study we did a study associated with how
people deploy within our data centers
and what we found out is that the single
thing that dominates all other costs
associated with a customer is the
movement of data everything else by
extension is cheap a lot of you have
heard of the thought and the term date
of gravity who meant who has heard of
this not many people David gravity is
the is the concept that the more that
you have the more data that you have the
more it tends to draw compute and other
data to it it acts very similarly
actually as a physical model associated
with if you said data has mass and the
more data it tends to draw things
together then you want to have then you
want to bring your compute and your
other data to it and it costs money to
move out of the gravitational well or
the data well associated with having
data in one particular place this is why
people sometimes say that data is sticky
it also affects your compute I don't
know how many of you I'm going to see
how many people laugh associated with
this one but this is if they're got many
many people but this is to a certain
extent the story of my life because you
try and do something where you assume
that the data is in located in one place
or you try and assume that the data is
located in the other and if you run your
models in the wrong place it runs like a
dog it's terrible it takes forever
because you are doing the literally the
most expensive thing that you can do in
computing and that is moving data around
so for all of recorded history we have
had this idea of we take the raw output
of the world the labor that is done the
output of sensors the output of the
world and we transport it to the means
of production these these computers
because the computers have always been
where it is but for the first time we
can ask a different question that has a
different answer that answer question is
where is compute compute has always been
centralized but what we are looking
forward to and we are frankly in the age
where compute is now decentralized
compute is everywhere and let me
illustrate this through a series of
three three examples the first is this
is a projection of this is a projection
of 2.7 billion tweets done in the
geographic area of Manhattan over a
single month period one of the things
that's interesting is that you can
actually deduce a lot of both areas of
interest as well as the grid structure
of Manhattan simply by looking at the
the location of these tweets now this
visualization was done by aggregating
the data up and putting it together but
the primary processing of this data the
creation of the tweet the initial
working was actually done on 2.7 billion
cell phones or tablets if you want to be
one of those people who holds it up and
takes pictures with it this if this was
yesterday this is today who knows what
this is
that's right that's a flight data
recorder people think of these as the
black boxes of of planes and they think
well they record everything in so you
can see it this is actually a really
crappy recorder of data I was talking
with a guy from GE and he said that the
new that they want to embed compute in
their airplanes and they need to because
the propulsion system alone in a 787
dreamliner generates five terabytes of
data each flight they throw away all
that data because it costs too much to
transmit it it costs too much to process
it and so therefore it is therefore they
do some averages and they use it to turn
on a light that says either you're like
your engine is fine or your engine is
blowing up that's all that they do and
if they start and they said we want to
embed the in processing intelligence in
our planes so that when we can start to
do meaningful analytics on the plane
without having to transmit all that data
down into a data center and do something
with it this is data gravity in action
when they do that they can then start
putting out the intelligence that's
associated with the analysis of the data
and saving really the only important
piece after I have that conversation
with the with the folks from GE I folks
conversation with someone from l3 who
actually has a system like this that
they put on trains these this is
currently deployed out in the world and
what they do is they analyze the systems
on the train as they are going forward
and they look for anomalies in this live
anomaly detection allows them to either
adjust the running mix of the train or
to flag it for immediate repair whenever
they see something and they estimate
that this saves me several millions of
dollars per train per year in terms of
missed maintenance costs
and increase and provides greater
reliability this is because they put the
compute where the data is how about the
future let's look at our cows one of the
things that struck me with with these
things was how big they were and the
simplicity of the computation and the
measurement that was being associated
with the what was what was being
communicated up what was communicated
the decision the intelligence associated
with it it was a single bit of data it
was this cow is in estrus or this cow is
not you can represent that with a single
bit where was the data the data was in
the field with the cow you could easily
embed a computer in that pedometer do
the analysis right there on the cow and
so haven't send a message when it has
something interesting to say yes this
cow happens to be going into estrus
because that was the only thing that
they were that was at least initially
the only thing that they were looking
for in doing that you can actually have
a radically cheaper infrastructure
because you're not dealing with as much
data and you can do it I where the data
is you don't move it around so what does
this mean for Python because this is PI
data after all first of all we need to
start thinking about Python in the small
a lot of what we are going for here is
how can i make python work on bigger and
bigger data sets turns out that a lot of
the things that we're talking about are
going to be associated with small data
sets and small devices and frankly
python doesn't have a great answer for
the most widely deployed of those than
the mobile devices although that's being
worked on interestingly we do have a
very good we have some very good things
when we go a little bit smaller the
Raspberry Pi the micro bit the micro
Python which runs on a variety of
microcontroller
it's actually really really good it
makes it very easy to control and run
your your analysis on a tiny tiny
computer that you can embed all over the
place but as data scientists as
engineers as people who are starting to
think about this you need to start
thinking about how can i make my
computations and my runtime fit on
something that is very small you also
need to start thinking about how does
this change the algorithms that you use
associated with with data and I would
suggest that we start looking for ways
in which this has changed in the past
specifically I think that we're going to
need to start looking a lot more at an
extended form of non-uniform memory
access now non-uniform memory access
arose it was theoretically available far
back but it really became an issue with
the rise of multiprocessors in the late
1990s specifically the opteron I are not
the opteron the athlon I think was the
first one to have a first PC to have a
NUMA aware architecture you had it in
some larger architectures before that
and what they found is that by saying
let's keep the data we're as close to a
particular processor as we can they
instead of putting out this abstraction
that all memory accesses are the same
they found that they could get from a 72
a 16 times speedup associated with a
associated with a uniform memory access
model now this obviously increased
overhead because you had to start
coordinating what these different
processors would do and as you have
added more and more course it became
more and more difficult but the fact
that you stopped saying data can be
anywhere and you started saying my data
is here made a huge difference this is
the same leap that we're going to need
to start making when we talk about data
being everywhere and processing being
everywhere because it is far more far
cheaper to process the data where it is
than to move it
moving data is the most expensive thing
that you will do think about the think
about the Dreamliner five terabytes of
data is really really expensive to move
off that plane but the information that
you can get out of analyzing it on the
plane that is small and valuable and can
be moved around the second thing that
you can I think that we're going to need
to start looking at our cache oblivious
algorithms now a cache oblivious
algorithm is an algorithm that is not
tuned to a particular cache size instead
what it does is it makes it and the
optimal use of any cash that is
available of any size minus some
constant minus some constant factors but
it it makes certain guarantees about the
ability to look the ability to access
certain types of data and look at them
in certain certain ways and says you
know what it doesn't matter if your data
is closed or your data is far I will be
able to provide you the best case
running time bounded within a certain
within a certain time bound that is
possible with the actual location of the
data and it turns out that these
algorithms are really really valuable
when you have caches it sounds like this
would be something that you would run on
without a cash no it means that it makes
optimal use of the cash regardless of
the size regardless of where the data is
now I want to go one loop around back to
this guy this actually has I said that
this was going to be just about data and
just about computing but it's also about
the social reality associated with the
control of information even if you go
into the pre computing era the control
of the data the control of the
information has been a key means of
political control associated with people
all the way back to the
Egyptians and the ancient Egyptians
having the ability to look at yourself
to analyze yourself to analyze the world
around you and to do that right where
you are is actually tremendously
powerful and it's tremendously
liberating because you don't necessarily
need to have all the data in the cloud
or to have all the data over there or
have the data someplace else under
someone else's control in order to get
the answers that you want out of it you
should start thinking about the
computing that is available right around
you the answers that are available right
around you and how that can be
empowering and interesting for you right
now questions